>> Katie: URGING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO BREAK AWAY
FROM THE WOKE IN A LAST-DITCH
EFFORT TO SAVE THE FORTUNES
BETWEEN THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
THE DEMOCRATS NEED TO WAKE UP
AND TAKE ON RADICAL ACTIVISM IN
THE PARTY BEFORE IT IS TOO LATE.
THE WARNINGS ON THE HEEL OF JILL
BIDEN APOLOGIZING AFTER
COMPARING HISPANIC PEOPLE TO
TACOS.
SO TYRUS, THEY SAY GO WOKE GO
BROKE.
>> Tyrus: THIS IS FALLING ON
DEAF EARS, NONE OF THEM ARE
LISTENING, AND WHOEVER RODE IT
IS PROBABLY ON THE SHORT-LIST TO
GET CANCELED IMMEDIATELY.
THEY BOUGHT INTO THIS AND THIS
IS THE PROGRESSIVE ISSUE ON WHAT
THEY WANT TO RUN ON, AND LO AND
BEHOLD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SAID
NO, THIS IS NOT HOW WE DO
THINGS.
THEY DOUBLE DOWN, THEY DON'T
CHANGE.
AND THIS INDIVIDUAL WHO SAW THE
LIGHT WAS PROBABLY NEVER ONBOARD
ANY LAND TILL YOU SEEING REAL
CHANGE IN POLICY OR ONE OF THESE
PROGRESSIVE LEADERS COME FORWARD
AND BE LIKE, WE MADE A MISTAKE,
WE ARE WRONG.
I FEEL HORRIBLE FOR MODERATE
DEMOCRATS IN REAL DEMOCRATS,
BECAUSE I GET MIXED UP IN THIS
IN ONE OF THE MOST FRUSTRATING
THINGS FOR ME ABOUT JOE BIDEN IS
THAT HE WAS ALWAYS A MODERATE
DEMOCRAT.
EVEN SOMETIMES I THOUGHT IT WAS
TOO MUCH ON CRIME.
BUT HE GETS IN THE WHITE HOUSE
AND HE BEATS THEM, THEY NEED HIM
TO GET IN AND THEN HE JUST FOLDS
TO THEIR AGENDA, WHICH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TECHNICALLY DID
NOT VOTE FOR, THEY VOTED FOR HIM
THINKING HE WOULD BRING BALANCE
AND ALL HE HAS DONE HAS BROUGHT
THIS PROGRESSIVE AGENDA AND THEY
ARE GOING TO BLAME IT ON HIM
INSTEAD OF CHANGING THE
MIND-SET.
AND AT LEAST ADMIT THE WRONG.
AT LEAST SAY, HEY, WE MADE SOME
MISTAKES.
FIRST WORLD PROBLEMS AREN'T THE
SAME AS REAL PROBLEMS, AND THEY
JUST GOOD FOR YOU, BUT THERE IS
NO ONE COMING ALONG WITH IT.
>> Katie: IS IT TOO LATE FOR
JOE BIDEN DOES SHED THE WOKE?
>> Lawrence: YEAH, IT'S TOO
LATE.
IT'S TOO LATE TO PIVOT AND
CHANGE ISSUES.
LOOK, I USE THIS ANALOGY A LOT,
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IT IS THE
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THE COUNTRY, I GO
EVERY SINGLE WEEK, GO TO DINERS
AND I TALKED TO MIDDLE AMERICA
OF WHAT IS WRONG WITH THE
COUNTRY AND THEN I GO BACK HOME
TO MY BARBERSHOP ALL POLITICS
AND BLACK AMERICA, AND THEY ARE
SAYING THE SAME EXACT THING.
SO WHEN YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENT
THAT HAS LOST BOTH GROUPS, YOU
KNOW THAT IT IS NOT JUST
WOKENESS, IT IS THE ABILITY TO
ADDRESS THE DAY-TO-DAY ISSUES
THAT ARE FACING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
MINOR FLORA SHOULD BE AN EXAMPLE
FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, SHE
DID SOMETHING THAT NO REPUBLICAN
IS ABLE TO DO.
SHE LOVES HER COUNTRY AND SHE
LOVES HER COMMUNITY AS WELL.
AND SHE DID NOT CHANGE WHO SHE
WAS, SHE DID NOT PUT ON SOME
FANCY SUIT.
SHE TALKED ABOUT HER HERITAGE
AND THE IMMIGRANTS AND SHE
TALKED ABOUT THE FOOD, SHE
TALKED ABOUT THE CRIME, AND SHE
TALKED ABOUT AND SAID THAT SHE
WAS PROUD TO BE AN AMERICAN.
IF REPUBLICANS CAN REPLICATE
THAT MODEL EVERY SINGLE DISTRICT
WHERE THERE IS A SWING DISTRICT,
THEY WILL WIN, NOT ONLY FOR
CENTER AMERICA, BUT BLACK
AMERICA.
>> Katie: I THINK THAT SHE
PROBABLY MAKE SOME REALLY GOOD
TACOS.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE
DEMOCRATS ARE SO FOCUSED ON
CULTURAL ISSUES, THEY WILL NEVER
APOLOGIZE AND SAY WE ARE SORRY
AND I WAS READING AN INTERESTING
QUOTE HERE THAT LATINOS ARE FED
UP, FORMER RADIO HOST DONNIE
ALEX SANDRA RENO TOLD FOX NEWS,
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY PROSECUTES
THE VOTE OF THE HISPANIC
POPULATION, THEY USE IT, THEY
ABUSE IT AND THEN THEY DISCARD
IT.
THEY DO IT EVERY SINGLE ELECTION
CYCLE.
I DON'T LIKE TO SEGREGATE THE
HISPANIC POPULATION, THEY ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NEEDS AND WHO
HAVE CONCERNS, WHO ARE FEARFUL
OF CRIME, WHO WORRY ABOUT GAS,
WHO WORRY ABOUT BUYING CHICKEN
AND HOW MUCH IT IS THIS WEEK.
YOU KNOW, I'M TIRED OF THE
SEPARATION AND I GET THAT THERE
ARE SUBCULTURES AND I RESPECT
THE SUBCULTURES IN THE COUNTRY,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, THE
DEMOCRATS IT IS TOO LATE FOR
THEM NOT TO BE WOKE.
JOE BIDEN DOES NOT KNOW IF HE IS
AWAKE OR ON AWAKE, SO HE DOES
NOT KNOW IF HE IS WOKE OR ON
WOKE, EGG AND THE TRANSITION.
>> Geraldo: I THINK THAT THE
HISPANICS PARTICULARLY ARE
INNATELY CONSERVATIVE.
THEY ARE SOCIALLY CONSERVATIVE
AND MANY, MANY WAYS.
THEY ARE FACE BASE -- A
FAITH-BASED, FAMILY ORIENTED AS
REAGAN SAID FAMOUSLY IN THE
'80s, THEY ARE REPUBLICANS
THEY JUST MAY NOT KNOW IT YET,
BUT THE REASON I THINK HISPANICS
CAN BE IS THE LARGEST MINORITY
GROUP IN THE COUNTRY, THERE IS
NO WAY THAT THE DEMOCRATS CAN
WIN WITHOUT A MAJORITY OF
HISPANICS.
AND IF THEY HAVE LOOKED AT
JOE BIDEN AND COMPANY LOSING
LATINOS, THEN I THINK THAT THEY
ARE DOOMED.
IF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS NOT